my name is anushka and
my topic is understanding the origin of
sars code 2 and comparison of covid
strains and their analysis
the 2019 coronavirus pandemic has
impacted the whole world causing
billions of people to become infected
and millions of deaths
several scientists and researchers
around the world conducted research that
led to the answers of several questions
that were unsolved at the outset of the
pendulum
a lot of research has been done and is
still being done
the virus is ever changing and evolving
nature has resulted in a wide range of
variations
the world health organization has
identified certain of these variants as
variants of concerns
due to their nature and behavior that
can be harmful to public health
these worries could stem from their high
transmissible character for example
different versions have different
mutations
which must be recognized accurately in
order to build a treatment plan or
preventive strategy to combat the
viruses propagation
during any therapeutic or preventive
research
understanding the changes in the
sequence knowing the mutations and so on
becomes extremely vital and crucial
the origin of coronavirus was a critical
topic that needed to be answered
before any important study could be
conducted
the animal and the geographical location
that are related to the virus the origin
of the virus are referred to as the
viruses origin
after figuring out the sarco
origin the next question is how the
virus got to humans and started
infecting them
informatics tools could be utilized
extensively to comprehend all of this
another set of questions that must be
answered before any therapeutic or
preventive study is what mutations have
occurred in the virus and how they have
affected the transmission infectivity
and other aspects of the virus
one of the most recent and dominating
mutation is the d614g
mutation which has proved to be
responsible for increased infectivity of
the virus
in the discipline of bioinformatics
there is a range of tools that can be
utilized to do research
this includes software such as eugene
for visualizing sequences and observing
changes in sequences
victory
for visualizing phylogenetic trees and
databases such as ncibi virus
the goal of the project was about
understanding the origin of the virus
by comparing different sequences from
three organisms humans pangolins and
bats and then retrieving 16 sequences
which included 10 unclassified sequences
one sequence each from the alpha variant
beta variant gamma variant delta variant
and omegran variant and one reference
genome
and then analyzing it further to know
and understand their lineages and
mutational patterns especially in spike
protein
because the viruses s protein also known
as spike protein is such an important
component of the virus keeping track of
the s-proteins changes is crucial
it is important to keep track of the
viruses mutational alterations and the
variations of concern
methodology
the first step was phylogenetic tree
analysis using tyne for server to know
the origin and the evolutionary pattern
of the virus
a phylogenetic tree is a very helpful
tool that can help understand
evolutionary patterns
ncbi virus database was searched for
sars of 2
after that
applying the required refine result
feature filters
the geographical location was set to
china since the virus originated from
there
the nucleotide completedness was set to
complete to eliminate any of the partial
sequences that would be there in the
results
and the host was set to pangolin
bat and humans
using the download button on the top of
the page the required database was
obtained
in addition to that the reference
sequence was also obtained which is also
available on ncbi virus
next step was to was the phylogenetic
analysis of the data set using the t by
info server
on the server the phylogenetic analysis
option was selected
next using the options given the files
were uploaded and four groups were made
namely
human charge cov2 bad corona virus
bad sarsko and pangolin coronavirus
after uploading all the files the
pipeline was made
the steps that were followed to make the
pipeline are shown in the picture
after making the pipeline it was then
ran
and named
in the output files section which was
obtained as the result of the pipeline
the median tree was downloaded and was
visualized using the factory software
the next step was performing multiple
sequence alignment and for the same the
msa output was obtained
multiple sequence alignment is also
known as msa and is the alignment of
three or more biological sequences
of equal or similar length
the homology and the evolutionary
relations between the sequences that are
being examined can be obtained from the
output we received
in the case of understanding the origin
of coronavirus multiple sequence
alignment was used to obtain the reason
why pangolin coronavirus is closer to
that of sars co2 than to bad
coronavirus to do the same msa was
performed and then visualized
the visualization of the msa output
obtained from the phylogenetic analysis
pipeline was performed using the unipro
eugene software
for this multiple sequence alignment
output was downloaded from the output
files
of phylogenetic analysis
then using eugene software the results
were visualized for msa at the
nucleotide level
after visualization of the results a
conclusion was drawn
after multiple sequence alive alignment
at the nucleotide level a similarity
index was obtained using the eugene
software and based on that index results
were observed and conclusions were drawn
after performing the steps of msa at the
nucleotide level msa was performed at
the amino acid level to know and
understand the sequence differences of
sarco at the amino acid level
for this
the file that contained the data for
multiple sequence alignment and the at
the amino acid level was downloaded
from the output files of the analysis
after understanding the origin of source
of 2 and concluding the results the next
step was to select a data set and work
on that data set to know the
similarities and penguin lineages of the
randomly selected 10 and classified
sequences
the data set
sequence
was retrieved from ncbi virus
which included 16 sequences containing
one
sequence each from
the alpha variant beta variant gamma
variant delta variant omegran variant
one reference sequence and ten
unclassified linear sequences
next is the phylogenetic analysis of the
dataset
after obtaining the sequences from ncbi
virus
phylogenetic analysis was performed
on the t bioinfo server the phylogenetic
analysis was selected and the files were
uploaded
after uploading the files the uploaded
files were placed in different groups
according
to the sequences
all the unclassified sequences were
placed in one group and the variants
were placed in different groups
after uploading all the required files
the pipeline was made
after the processing of the pipeline is
completed from the output files the
phylogenetic tree file was downloaded
downloaded and visualized using victory
the msa output at nucleotide level was
downloaded and was visualized using the
unipro eugene software
and from the output temp files the file
for msa at amino acid level was
downloaded and visualized using the
unipro eugene software
the next step was identifying the
lineages of the sequences
for the lineage of the unclassified
sequences
gis aid was used
whereas for the lineage of the
classified sequences the curve lineages
database was used
the jis 8 clades can be used to know the
bengaline lineage of the unclassified
sequences
after that this next step was
identifying the most prevalent mutation
among the unclassified sequences
after understanding the pangolin
lineages of the sequences
specific mutations were looked into to
understand the sequence much more
efficiently
this was done using the pangolin lineage
list and outbreak.info
majorly the s protein was looked at
since it is a key component of the virus
that affects its infectivity
results and discussion
the phylogenetic tree that was
visualized using the fig tree software
shows that it is evident that the bat
coronavirus emerged first or in other
words was the earliest one when
considering the origin of the
coronavirus
and may have mutated to give rise to
human sarcophagus and pangolin
coronavirus
the evolutionary relationship between
sars code 2 and pangolins is closer
since they are they are enclaves closer
to each other
after analyzing the phylogenetic tree
obtained using the phylogenetic analysis
pipeline
from the same output files msa file were
downloaded
it was present under the temp files
under the phylogenetic output files
the unipro eugene software was used to
visualize these sequences
the results of the multiple sequence
alignment show that in comparison to
pringle in corona viruses and sar scope
2
bad coronaviruses shows higher amount of
variations and mutations
the next step
that was to quantify the similarities
among the sequences
this was done using the similarity index
matrix offered by the eugene software
to understand the similarities between
the sequences and to effectively compare
them a quantified data table was
obtained using the eugene software which
had a similarity index of sequences
it was done with respect to reference 0.
this similarity index shows that there
is an 85 percent similarity between
starscore 2 and pangolin coronaviruses
whereas the similarity percentage
between the sequence of saskof2 and bad
coronaviruses is in a range of 78 to 79
percent
this shows that the similarity between
the sequences of sars and pangolin
coronavirus is higher than
the similarity between the sequences of
sars and bad coronavirus
in other words pangolin coronavirus is
more similar to sars cov2 than bad
coronavirus as per the similarity index
as shown by eugene
this was msa at the nucleotide level
in the next step multiple sequence
alignment was done of the four groups
namely human sars code two
bad coronavirus bad sarcophagus and
pangolin coronavirus at the amino acid
level following
similar steps as those
of the
msa at the nucleotide level
the sequences were also visualized using
the unipro eugene software
unlike the multiple sequence alignment
at the
nucleotide level
the dissimilarity index was obtained
using the eugene software in the msa at
amino acid level
the results that were obtained from the
dissimilarity index shows
about seven percent to nine percent
dissimilarity among the pangolin corona
virus and human seroscope two
whereas the results of the comparison of
sequences of bad coronavirus and human
sascov 2 shows a dissimilarity of 15 to
17
and hence similar to that is conclusions
made by msa at the nucleotide level star
scope 2 has a greater similarity with
the pangolin coronavirus compared to
that of the bat coronavirus
another indication that can be obtained
from the results is that not every
difference which was at the nucleotide
level got translated into the amino acid
level
this can be implied because the
nucleotide level has a greater
percentage of variations than be amino
acid level
this refers to that pangolin coronavirus
is more comparable and similar to human
size cov2 than bad coronavirus
next are the results of the phylogenetic
analysis of the dataset sequences
the dataset was obtained you and
compiled using the ncbi virus database
the phylogenetic tree was obtained using
the t bioinfo server phylogenetic
analysis pipeline and was visualized
using the factory software
the results that were concluded using
the phylogenetic tree
are
that
unclassified sequence 9 and unclassified
sequence 7 are close to omicron sequence
unclassified sequence 1 unclassified
sequence 2 unclassified sequence 8 and
unclassified sequence 10 are closely
related to each other
the group consisting of unclassified
sequence 1 2 8 and 10
is close to the group consisting of
unclassified sequence 9 7 and omegran
sequence
unclassified sequence 6 is closely
related to unclassified sequence 5 and
the gamma variance sequence
unclassified sequence 4 and the delta
sequence are closely related to the
alpha sequence
even though unclassified sequence 3 and
the beta sequence are on different
branches of the phylogenetic tree but
are closely placed to each other
performing the phylogenetic analysis and
the msa analysis
the next step was to know the pangolin
lineage of the sequences
firstly the pangolin lineage of the
variants of concern was obtained
this was done using the pangolin lineage
software
the results that were obtained are
that the sequence of con variant of
concern alpha has lineage as b point one
point one point seven
the sequence of variant of concern beta
has lineage as b point one point three
five one
the sequence of variant of concern delta
has lineage as b point one point six one
seven point two
the sequence of variant of concern gamma
has lineage as p point one
the sequence of variant of concern
omicron has lineage as b 1.1
the sequence of
reference genome has lineage as b
the next part was to know the pangolin
lineages of the unclassified sequences
this was done using the jis 8 software
according to the results
unclassified sequence 1 2 8 and 10 have
played as gra
unclassified sequence 3 has played as gh
and classified sequence 4 and 5 have
played as g
unclassified sequence 6 has played as gr
whereas unclassified sequences 7 and 9
have
played as other
these clades can help determine the
pangolin lineages of the unclassified
sequence since they
were not determined using the pangolin
lineage database
plate gra has dominant penguin lineage
as b point one point five two nine and
its descendants be a point one and b a
point two
plate gr has dominant pangolin lineage
as b point one point one
plate gh has dominant lineages as
b point one point one one three and b
point one point three five one
plate g has dominant lineage as b point
one point eight zero and b point one
the clade which shows as other refers to
that they don't match the required
criteria which the other clades do
final conclusions that can be drawn are
unclassified sequence 1 2
8 and 10 have the lineage
as that of omicron and its descendants
ba 0.1 and ba 0.2
unclassified sequence 3 has the lineage
as b 0.1.113
unclassified sequence 4 and unclassified
sequence 5 have the dominant lineages as
b point 1
unclassified sequence 6 has the pangolin
lineage as b
1.1
whereas unclassified sequence 7 and
unclassified sequence 9 don't match the
criteria the other sequences do
and hence have been marked as other but
according to the phylogenetic tree
analysis they are closer to the omicron
variant
next are the results of mutation
analysis using outbreak dot info
for different lineages that are related
to specific plates mutations can be
tracked and observed using outbreak dot
info soft database
the most prevalent mutation that can be
observed in the lineages is
d614g
in locations where sars cov2 isolates
expressing a d614g
mutation as seen above
the viral spike s protein prevails for
some time
indicating that the d614g modification
increases the transmission of the virus
and its infectivity
coronavirus is a group of different
viruses including sars42 which is
responsible for the covet 19 pandemic
coronavirus is a single strand rna virus
which refers to the fact that the
genetic information of coronavirus is
encoded in its rna
understanding the origin and identity of
a virus is a very crucial step to
initiate appropriate research for both
curative and preventive research
this would help understand the origin of
covet 19
to understand the jump of the virus and
the sequential changes that led to the
virus to start infecting human beings
to understand the evolutionary
relationships and many other questions
phylogenetic analysis and other methods
were incorporated into the project
from file the phylogenetic and msa
analysis it is evident that the backed
coronavirus evolved initially
or was the original coronavirus and
when examining the origin of
coronaviruses and that it may have
mutated to give rise to the human
sarcoph2 and pangolin coronavirus
humans are scoffed to win pangolin
coronavirus have a closer evolutionary
relation since they are in plates that
are more closely related or placed to
each other
the bat coronavirus in comparison to
that of sars cove ii and pangolin
coronavirus has more mutations
this shows the organism that might have
been responsible for the virus spreading
to human beings and causing a pandemic
these results were used to conclude that
humans are supposed to and other
has more similarities with pangolin
coronavirus than to bad coronavirus
mutations in a viral strain can bring a
variety of changes ranging from reduced
infectivity to increasing its
infectivity many folds
and
hence it comes
very importantly to understand the
origin and mutations to understand a
virus
in this project the pangolin lineage of
the different sequences was analyzed to
further understand the most common
mutation out of the 10 unclassified
sequences
pangolin which stands for phylogenetic
assignment of named global outbreak
is a tool for the implementation of the
nomenclature of the lineages of sars
proof2
the lineage was identified using two
databases namely just 8 and pangolin
lineage
the two databases helped identify the
lineages of the unclassified sequences
and the classified sequences
after the phylogenetic and msa analysis
results were drawn and it was identified
with sequences closer in evolutionary
patterns to which sequence
after getting to know the most common
mutation it was easier to understand the
sequences and the virus
the most common was the d614g mutation
the d614g mutation has proved to
increase and enhance the infectivity of
the virus
this point mutation has taken over
others in terms of prevalence
among the sequences that were selected
for the project showed that most common
was the d614g mutation
thank you